might not have noticed but the dow jones
fell over
797 points today
it is now infecting the markets
worldwide all the major averages
plummeting today
food prices skyrocketing fuel costs are
surging to the highest level since 2008.
oil prices have skyrocketed to their
highest price since 2008. what they're
over seven bucks a gallon over the
weekend
oh there it is 6.99 for a regular
inflation at its highest point since the
1970s all of this is creating what even
the washington post admits
is a deeply pessimistic nation
but rather than confronting the decline
of america under biden and then trying
to fix it the media and even some of the
gop are desperately selling another war
in terms of the no-fly zone we've done
it before we did it in iraq we did it in
bosnia uh we we did it in libya if nato
is not ready to confront russia
militarily in the skies how nato is
going to defend eastern flank of its
organization by rearming and sustaining
the ukrainian air force they can
continue to protect their own skies
now all of these problems could have
been prevented if we had a competent
government but we do not
biden should have insisted on a
realistic assessment of the situation in
ukraine instead his team kept open the
prospect of nato membership for ukraine
which putin said he was never going to
accept
in retrospect that was likely a huge
huge huge mistake
now of course putin didn't attack
ukraine under trump because he knew that
america was stronger and more practical
under his leadership
trump was a pro-energy nationalist who
wasn't about to get rolled into
supporting russia's natural gas pipeline
into europe
and from day one though the white house
pelosi schumer they've worked overtime
to turn back every policy of trump's
predecessor biden's predecessor that
worked actually to make america stronger
and more powerful here and in europe
now americans are made to pay a price
for biden's madness
a year ago who could have imagined seven
dollar a gallon gasoline prices not even
i
as for the media who seemed relieved to
be able to change the subject
they don't like the devastation in
ukraine of course they don't but they
also don't seem bothered at all
that americans are hurting in profound
ways
think about how miserable
miserable the white house press corps
was let's say in i don't know kind of
the end of 2019
what was happening then well that's when
we had energy independence
that's when we had low inflation
rising wages even for blue collar
workers
we also had record low unemployment
we had good trade deals
and we had no new wars
it didn't matter that investor in
consumer confidence was an all-time high
or that optimism was robust all the way
around in fact
that annoyed our media so much
and some of the other characters i just
mentioned they had to set upon to
destroy donald trump
donald trump is
a russian operative the 101 contacts
between trump's team and russia-linked
operatives russia hacked our election
that was a 9 11 scale event
and of course when biden got in
he and his band of saboteurs set a
course to radically change america
from the way our children view our
founding to the way we recruit and train
our military to the way we power our
cars and to the way we look at
citizenship even
they spent trillions of dollars which
just drove inflation through the roof
and then they refused to admit that
inflation was actually a real thing
and now they're telling you now they're
telling you
it's time for more sacrifice
so true that the world needs to be
prepared for a very long difficult road
ahead
what biden did to america in just over a
year is what he's doing to himself
politically
he and his party are poised for a
historic route in november and if he
thinks his 10 minutes of discussing the
tragedy in ukraine is going to help him
he's just wrong again
people will continue to be killed in
ukraine and it is horrific
but our elites keep pushing the lie that
people in ukraine and here are somehow
protected by the rules-based
international order
that's somehow going to fix things we'd
have to go back to that that is wrong
under trump they were protected
by the usa
but once we became too weak under biden
to protect anyone well things started to
collapse abroad
when china berated lincoln remember that
in alaska and trashed america
that showed us what they were trying to
do it was ugly and my prediction is
biden will continue to be humiliated by
china
as for those who say talking about china
as a dodge you saw that today
well it's the only way to realistically
assess though isn't it what's happening
in ukraine because china is a major
check on our ability to affect the
situation
every bad thing that is happening is
only happening now because our elites at
some point in time thought it was okay
to make china the most powerful country
in the world
so now here we are it's back to the
1970s the u.s has weakened under biden
we're humiliated by a smaller power like
russia we're divided at home we're
burdened with horrific inflation and
economic problems
it's all self-inflicted
by a white house and a political
establishment that has failed the people
who pay the bills they've done it far
too many times
but what the left will not admit yet
is that ukraine shows us in graphic gory
tragic detail how globalization
ultimately fails
because the elites thought that somehow
we could curtail evil with all in again
the international norms the new global
order the global reset whatever you want
to call it
that wasn't just idealistic it was
dangerous and it was stupid
the only thing that has kept bad actors
in check
was an america that was economically
strong and culturally cohesive
when we lose not just one but both of
those things
we're not going to just see suffering
abroad we're going to endure plenty of
our own here
the only good news
is that elections are now less than
eight months away
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else